[Musique]
alors bienvenue à la planète peu importe
où vous vous trouvez sur l'un des huit
continent et bien aujourd'hui on est là
pour vous c'est un temps canada en
direct de montréal sur ces images de
toronto habile le qui fait compétition à
lorient depuis tant d'années eh bien on
vous accueille à cette émission en
direct du canada
autour de la table on a deux collègues
de travail
marie-jo vert bonjour bonjour stéphane
et samir ben jafar qui cette semaine ne
travaillent avec nous en plus de
travailler dans une section autres dans
la section arabe donc ce travail avec
vous cette semaine mais merci de m'avoir
invité aujourd'hui et stéphane comme
c'est toujours un plaisir d'être présent
ici
en fait ça bien s'est invitée à
l'émission et sa fête le 200e droit de
trois semaines à peu près oui parce
qu'il l'a dit il faudrait que tu invites
telle personne est l'émission tu vois
c'est très intéressant je dis oui
d'accord mais ce qu'il ne sait pas c'est
que on a un peu trafiqué les choses il
ya plus qu'un éviter aujourd'hui
l'édition hockey et le sujet que de
l'émission que vous pensiez qui était le
sujet des missions c'est parfait alors
je vous présente la vidéo 5 images au
saas et de stéphane parent crèche cinq
images pour que vous essayez de me dire
c'est quoi le sujet aujourd'hui et tous
ceux qui regardent en ce moment peuvent
jouer le même jeu tout le monde part
avec la même base d'égalité c'est à dire
l'un connaît sans égalité des chances
alors regarde ça ça ça en vienne ou du
temps ça du côté de la technique
aujourd'hui 500 lignes et c'est vrai
qu'on est une tempête de neige cette
semaine donc donc les choses bougent à
plein du lendemain alors ça ça parle
devait donc mode de transport gym a
certainement des vieux véhicules
probablement que ça soye en sera
question ça c'est un producteur
d'électricité de ce que vous pensez
alternance vous vous y connaissez vous
êtes normalement pas arrêté et il il
aimait ces choses là qu'est ce que c'est
ça ça c'est une turbine
le secteur électrique si oui sur la
piste alors c'est quoi le sujet
aujourd'hui écouter les transports
électriques
on peut rien vous cacher c'est une
émission pour ceux qui veulent dire du
mal des véhicules électriques
ah oui
parce que c'est dommage tout n'est pas
parfait dans la vie ouais mais il ya eu
beaucoup de bonnes publicité faite pour
l'auto électrique approche j'en ai
acheté une
je me suis laissé avoir donc je dévoile
tout j'ai un prix juif pro électrique
mais j'entends des choses
des fois ok j'ai pas répondre moi-même
je ne sais pas quoi répondre
quand on dit mais tu sais les batteries
d'auto électrique ça pollue énormément
oui et le style d'une auto électrique
aussi à la fin s'est produit en moi j'ai
été choqué quand j'ai lu cet article sur
radio canada il ya quelques mois mais ça
m'a enfin ça c'était vraiment se moquer
ça marche ça m'a poussé à aller chercher
encore plus prendre en profondeur pour
voir est ce que c'est vrai bon s'essaya
les pour et les contre je pense que
notre invité peut-être réglera la
plupart des discours aussi beaucoup les
débats autour la façon où ce qu'on va
chercher et ce qu'on fait pour pouvoir
produire les métaux qu'on va utiliser
pour les batteries électriques métaux
précieux oui ben aussi comment est-ce
que l'électricité cancan avec laquelle
en charge la voiture à ce qu'elle est
pour lui rendre
je sais pas le temps de faire le tour de
la planète comme vous le désirez mais on
va faire un bout de piste enceinte
rassurez-vous tout commence par cette
première boule avant d'aller à vitry
huit premiers jeux de la grosse boule
aujourd'hui 20 vous la perdre c'est la
tradition semboules par émission à perte
et aussi la question la fiche pour tout
le monde pour le plaisir de tous et
chacun en subventions combien vont
coûter
je vous donne une commune préambule
d'abord l'objectif du québec merci
d'avoir cent mille véhicules électriques
sur les routes et on offre 8000 $ aux
contribuables d'accord qui veut acheter
une auto électrique neuve alors la
question est la suivante en subventions
convient monde vont coûter aux
contribuables canadiens
la présence de ces cent mille véhicules
électriques
est ce que c'est au total 8 millions
d'âmes en subventions 80 millions de
dollars dans subventions 800 millions de
dollars en subventions ou encore ma
préférée aucune de ces réponses pour moi
c'est non pas y avoir qu'une seule
réponse pourquoi moi aussi et parce que
vous avez pris à cent mille
contribuables canadiens
l'écueil à levie 1000 $ au québec mais
ya 5000 au canada non je sais ça on
affiche la bonne réponse a fait au total
parfois ça me remet à 2000 dollars de
subventions par véhicules additionnels
et puis ça fait combien c'est en
millions de dollars non ces reliques
s'en fait un milan 300 millions n'ont
transmis le courrier transmis les noms
des provinces qui ont décidé qu'ils ont
reculé sur la subvention et c'est le cas
de nos tares oui l'ontario il a reculé
mais c'est aller en cours mais je ne
sais pas s'il a entre concernées en
cours quatorze mille dinars de
subventions en ontario ceux qui
voulaient acheter un véhicule électrique
jusqu'à ou disons les premiers mois de
l'an dernier
alors écoutez cette question de la
subvention des véhicules aux véhicules
électriques et des gens qui disent mais
écoutez on offre ça aux gens en général
qui ont un peu plus d'argent que la
moyenne alors tous les contribuables
même les plus pauvres contribuer à cet
enrichissement des peluches
est ce qu'on devrait faire ça ou est-ce
qu'on n'aurait pas adopter d'autres
stratégies pour parler des aspects
négatifs dont on discute souvent dans
les médias concernant l'automobile autos
électriques pour l'automobile 06 sec le
dernier pardonnez moi alors on a un
invité première invitée aujourd'hui et
on va aller le chercher pas loin d'ici
en fait je pense qu'il est à montréal
avec de l'association des véhicules
électriques du québec et il participe
pas beaucoup d'entre vous allez le voir
souvent la télévision
simon pierre rioux monsieur rioux bons
jours plus tard dans quelques minutes on
va vous voir même au volant de véhicules
électriques en train de tester pour
radio-canada un modèle en particulier je
pense que c'était peut-être à l'occasion
d'un salon de l'auto électrique à
montréal y en a eu quelques-uns d'abord
répondant à cette première question
soyons soyons vilain si vous voulez
éviter
pourquoi est-ce qu'on subventionne des
des consommateurs qui ont les moyens de
s'acheter un véhicule électrique
en fait je réponde à la question parce
la réponse aider c'est vraiment aucune
de ces réponses parce que c'est le
marché du carbone qui va pouvoir offrir
ces contributions là donc ce n'est pas
le contribuable canadien qui paye pour
ces le marché du carbone
merci la société ou des grands pollueurs
et pollués a dans ce temps là il va y
avoir des subventions
si on arrête le marché du carbone unia
subventions puis on sent lui faudrait
que ce soit les contribuables qui payent
qui pense oui il peut y avoir des
baisses niveau là donc j'adore j'adore
votre choix de régulation sous jacent à
cette question-là 1 milliard 300
millions $ en voici ce que disent les
gens qui sont les apôtres du transport
en commun à montréal qui voudraient des
prolongements de métro ici et là gare à
gauche et à droite et nord au sud
alors pourrait prolonger d'au moins un
kilomètre le métro de montréal avec un
milliard trois cents millions
pourquoi ce qu on n'investira pas plutôt
dans le transport en commun plutôt que
d'encourager l'utilisation de véhicules
électriques
il faut réparer les routes il faut
continuer à encourager l'utilisation de
l'automobile
écoutez c'est ça fait que on investit
déjà énorme émanant transports en commun
pourquoi on irait ben ali de l'argent
des gens qui sont bien nantis
en fait c'est peut-être ce qui est en ce
moment c'est que pour débuter un
changement notoire influence déjà fait
un peu plus d'argent qu'ils sont
capables de se permettent d'acheter le
véhicule électrique pour après ça les
gens mon regard des véhicules un caprin
ou leurs ventes une marche l'occasion on
le vend moins cher
puis il vécut le vol de véhicules
électriques
on peut s'attendre à une durée de vie de
1 million de kilomètres à vin et des
problèmes donc le véhicule va durer
beaucoup plus longtemps qu'en bâtiments
et véhicules est en dessous après 208 km
on commence à se poser question est ce
que c'est un de levante ce que lors des
problèmes mécaniques
la batterie et ball tour 1 ghz et le
moteur est bon pour un bleu millions de
kilomètres donc c'est des véhicules qui
sont faites pour durer
quand on arrive après kaisin elle le
changement de la batterie ne se fait pas
automatiquement la batterie peut encore
rebondir en tout environ 70 % de sa
capacité initiale donc sa vie que tu
voiture est très longtemps
pour les capable de diminuer les gaz est
fait symbolique n'ont rien côté
environnemental qui est importante
sa part cuisse ces restes d'un véhicule
qui plus dispendieux initialement parce
que c'était une très petite production
au produit environ pour certaines
factures et les soixante mille véhicules
pour un véhicule ou pour la planète au
complet donc sont près de 5000 véhicules
versus 2 millions de micra par exemple
le coût de véhicules soit vous avez que
son a produit par millions heureusement
ça va être intéressant c'est lorsqu'on
va commencer à produire ces véhicules la
centaine de billy par millions
d'exemplaires estimant on sera plus
obligé avoir de subventions aux à new
content
excusez moi nous avons un temple pour
l'utilisation des véhicules électriques
l'acheteur bénéficie de subventions ils
utilisent la route tout ça mais il n'y a
aucune contribution a par exemple comme
si moi j'ai un véhicule à essence je
dois payer des taxes et pour
l'utilisation de la route tout ça pour
quoi celui qui tue le véhicule
électrique
il est exclu de ça il en plus de ça il
reçoit des subventions en plus il est
classé dans la catégorie qui a de
l'argent qui peut s'acheter des choses
que le commun des contribuables ne peut
pas généralement m'a écouté les taxes
sont jamais payés sur des utilisations
électricité eau est utilisée sur les
réseaux de rechange public donc il
s'appelle taxes qui sont utilisés
l'argent est réinvesti de toute façon
parce que oui à l'utilisation de
véhicules pour des beaucoup moins cher
donc par exemple si je fais 20 mille
kilomètres par année
je vais payer 2500 $ en essence ou je
paie 300 da racing
mais cet argent là que je vais
économiser jeunes rives
ce tir acheter d'autres trucs à faire
des voyages et l'argent revient de toute
façon dans la société d'une façon
différente mais il y revient de toute
façon ce qui va arriver en ce moment
c'est un avantage
le bel avantage de marrons à payer de
taxes
raison mais sa présidence est devenu par
exemple qui ont décidé d'avoir une
contribution des propriétaires des
véhicules électriques
et l'on chérit as un ballon pour
l'utilisation des gourous montrent un
compas présentement au québec
c'est certain que lorsqu'il va y avoir
une présence plus importante de
véhicules électriques sont nombreux ça
va dépendre pour nous de regarder taxe
kilométrique ouvre justement aider à
soutenir à venir les écritures
merci est ce que vous entendez beaucoup
parler des problèmes liés à la
production de ces piles électriques pour
les voitures
parce que on entendait parler que de lui
venir peut-être chercher de ces métaux
précieux au québec qui coûte plus cher à
exploiter on va par exemple en amérique
du sud dans quoi de la bolivie d'un quad
et certains pays chercher du matériel
qui est plus facile alors on détruit des
châtels dans l'équipe parce que ça coûte
beaucoup moins cher
sk pas être danger moment donné de avoir
un mauvais impact sur l'environnement en
même temps qu'on développe cette cette
filière qui se pose est de plus propre
c'est important qu'on puisse bien des
choses
on parle ici de coban béni où c'est plus
difficile
on essaie de diminuer l'utilisation du
cobalt dans les batteries de nouvelle
maintien pour s'assurer qu'on reproche
justement l exploiter des mines dans des
pays en voie de développement qui
pourrait vraiment mais c'est imprécis et
heureusement mais on diminue de beaucoup
d'utilisation du global dans les
batteries appuyé par la suite vous voir
que je pense que vous avez un autre
expert au niveau des bêtes aux plus
gradés pas aimé ça change énormément on
veut changer la composition des
batteries
c'est ce qu'on peut toujours une
batterie oui présentement c'est lithium
c'est le cobalt manganèse
mais on va changer la composition plus
de se débattre et des matins qui sont
plus facilement accessibles sont plus
une insertion je n'en sais pas plus -
j'ai également les choses changent
présentement s'expose utilisent des
méthodes et procédés plus écologique
oui même si rio moi j'ai toujours ce
souci là les gens qui ont des véhicules
électriques ils sont supposés avoir des
maisons pour pouvoir au moins les
charges et mais c'est pas tout le monde
qui est propriétaire et ceux qui
habitent dont deux dans des appartements
comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent utiliser
des voitures électriques ils peuvent pas
les charger dans la rue j'imagine que
c'est c'est pas pratique 12 vous dans
votre association est ce que vous avez
pensé à ce type de de clientèle à cette
catégorie de clientèle pour les voitures
électriques
absolument nous c'est important que les
tout le monde ait accès à des véhicules
électriques on s'est battu pour que les
gens puissent aussi acheter des
véhicules usagés un rabais aux véhicules
électriques usagés au québec selon
certaines règles à suivre mais on sait
que c'est pas tout le monde qui sont
propriétaires de maisons qui ont pouvons
installer une borne de recharge
on peut recharger à 100 des votes ont
besoin une borne de recharge de plus en
plus de bande se ruent dans les grandes
villes dont montréal et québec les
autres villes peuvent vraiment ça peut
être un peu plus compliqué on a des bons
de recharge rapide permettent de
recharger le véhicule en 20 à 30 minutes
dont compris d'user ses bornes là pour
faire le change d'une fois par semaine
ou deux fois par semaine pour être
capable de taper de longs trajets
quotidiens
on se sert des choses qui valent mais
par la suite on sa fin avec les avants à
magasiner beaucoup plus d'énergie à plus
de kilométrage
justement quand tu es seulement les
bandes de rechange ultra rapide pour
faire dès le changement 5 à 10 minutes
environ
donc la texture riche beaucoup c'est ce
qu'on aimerait capable de faire parce
que quand on regarde seulement au québec
ni sanguin ailleurs d'amande
c'est que ça sera pas toujours le cas on
pourra pauvres à charger faut que des
infrastructures de la charge des travaux
c'est plus facile pour les gens
complet monsieur rioux on voulait
continuer à tirer à boulet rouge sur
vous il reste plus de munitions assure
qu'on avait d'autres questions mais on
va aller vers un autre spécialiste de la
question du des véhicules automobiles et
des batteries notamment ses fameuses
batteries et sur lesquelles reposent
beaucoup de questions notamment
environnementales merci beaucoup d'avoir
mis la table aujourd'hui
et puis vous représentez bien le cadet
des positif dès lors quand on parle de
batterie merci beaucoup
alors s'est invitée avec lequel le
courant passait bien et à simon kirby et
c'est bien de l'association des
véhicules électriques du québec 2e tour
la grosse boule
oui mais je retiens jours apple avait
déjà perdu 20 points parce que vous
répondiez pas la bonne réponse est non
j'attendais vous truquez mais bien
passée voire franchement là vous êtes
vous êtes duc des étudiants de vendredi
vous écoutez bien bon écoute et voici la
question va l'affiché vous avez pas
besoin d'écouter le besoin de lire et
vous quelle est la taxe minimale en
norvège sur un véhicule précédent un
moteur à combustion ici on offre des
subventions à l'achat d'accord en
norvège ne dit pas question d'impliquer
l'argent des contribuables ou des fonds
de du carbone là dedans on va demander
aux gens de payer si j'achète encore un
de ces vieux véhicules avec moteur à
combustion polluantes qui sont mauvais
alors est-ce que c'est 5000 dollars en
taxe minimale sur un véhicule vieux
genre qu'on impose la ville à sa famille
est ce que c b dix mille dollars
est ce que c'est c'est 15 mille dollars
mon dieu ou est ce que c'est des 20000
dollars pays qui veut avoir tous les
véhicules électriques d'ici quelques
années c'est un pays qui produit du
pétrole oscillaient de gaza attendait là
enfin c'est pas évident c'est pas
évident on offre aux quais treize mille
dollars en subventions un automobiliste
québécois et là on est ce qu'on va taxer
15000 dollars en en vain jusque ça va
être si la bonne réponse
est-ce que ça va être bon y'a pas aucune
de ces réponses ben écoutez moi je vais
vers le haut parce que ça va plus dans
un pays où il ya 19 ans
quelque part ce qu'il est vendeur de
mauvaise réponse je donnerai plus
vendeur de bijoux l'usl
alors je devrai avec samir ou tentez
votre chance
on va aller sur nohain près de 5000 $ de
taxes pour juste pour alors on y va on
va aller sur c'est un peu comme le jeu
du pendu allait tomber tous les deux
c'est bien regarder la réponse c'est
quand même du fixe alors là ils ont
commis deux véhicules électriques
maintenant bah écoutez c'est la moitié
des véhicules à ce moment qu'ils sont
des véhicules électriques on sont vendus
mais que ça peut faire la leçon du côté
de la norvège
on continue à produire du pétrole à être
très à bénéficier de sa et en même temps
pénalise les gens chez nous on veut bien
paraître à la maison met en avant notre
pétrole ailleurs chose est certaine
c'est bien conduire en norvège coûte
plus cher qu'ici c'est la moyenne là
alors écoutez on a quelqu'un que qui est
un invité spécial de samir ben jaafer
cette semaine et vous à nu le présentez
vous l'avez rencontré personne aidée à
son laboratoire
oui il s'agit maintenant d'une vedette
des médias puisqu'on le connaît il a
passé à quelques émissions de télévision
karim zaghib qui est directeur du centre
d'excellence à l'électrification des
transports à hydro québec et il y a de
remporter un prix important je vous
laisse les deux discuter on va tous
discuter avec moi même donc karim hijazi
bonjour vous avez karim bonjour donc
c'est un homme qui est très accessible
oui j'ai eu l'occasion dans l'est
visitez karim avoir le centre d'excel de
centres d'excellence en électrification
des transports c'est ça et stockage
d'énergie et stockage d'énergie les
batteries oui donc karim comment le
présenter karim il est récipiendaire du
prix lionel boulet saisi le prix lionel
boulet c'est l'un des prix l'un des prix
scientifiques que remet le gouvernement
du québec chaque année à un scientifique
ou un groupe de scientifiques karim il
est spécialisé aussi dans les batteries
et les batteries lithium et qui dit
batterie lithium il faut se rappeler que
cette année le prix nobel de chimie a
été remis à deux chercheurs un japonais
un américain qui sont spécialisés dans
le domaine et dans l'un d'eux et 1 2 il
a travaillé avec moi lorsqu'un des cieux
mais bobby c'est ça parce que karim a
fait un passage au japon
si je comprends dire exactement passé il
faut il ya beaucoup de choses à dire à
propos duquel on va vous laisser tordre
et monsieur karim
merci de l'invitation je suis oui je
remercie beaucoup le québec et le
gouvernement du québec pour le prix
lionel boulet et lionel boulet si le
fondateur de l'association le centre de
recherche au québec et cie est un
honneur de travailler ici aussi c'est
moi je suis toujours ici devant les
caméras mais j'ai une équipe qui
travaille avec moi les gens qui
travaillent dans l'ombre donc d'une
équipe à shawinigan kipawa rennes est
une équipe en france et nous
développement des batteries lithium ion
battery tout solide et il ya peu de gens
qui savent que hydro québec aujourd'hui
c'est la seule compagnie au monde en
particulier un mail d'une eau qui est un
centre de recherche et les batteries la
recherche du développement de batteries
ça commençait dans cette place depuis
1967 et aujourd'hui j'ai dit toujours
peut-être avec une fierté aujourd'hui a
pas un téléphone portable ou un
ordinateur ou une voiture électrique ou
moins à l'intérieur d'une batterie un
élément qui est meurtri par hydro québec
je peux vous faire de faire mais je
pense que tu es cela vous a battu au fil
d'arrivée 1 ça fait cinq ans que ça vous
y travaillez donc je fais des blagues
évidemment est ce que quand vous parlez
du des applications qu'on retrouve comme
ça sur le marché partout c'est que
probablement insoupçonnées on
on ne sait pas comme consommateur que ça
vient que ça a été fait chez vous et
coupet que vous faisiez viande à la pâte
si on voit tout à l'heure une parler de
prix john goodenough mais peu connu le
projet de base qui a été breveté moi
j'étais jeune mais hydro québec il le
cnrs qui montre la conception d'une
batterie lithium-ion et la conception de
la batterie solide ça a été breveté par
hydro québec qui par le service monsieur
john goodenough qui on travaille depuis
25 ans ces récepteurs de duperie prix
nobel en chimie
c'est que le rôle d'hydro-québec nous
notre rôle c'est de faire la recherche
et développement et on s'associe avec le
manufacturier
si vous prenez l'exemple de tesla oui
l'exemple de tesla c'est un bon exemple
mais la batterie de tesla s'est
développée par panasonic par les
japonais et la compagnie qui a développé
qui a commercialisé la première batterie
lithium-ion
si sony donc juste la conception que 10
fois si mal connu oui tesla elle est
l'amie un moteur électrique avec des
batteries de panasonic avec un habitant
mais des fois on oublie que le crédit et
il appartient à des compagnies
japonaises sont faits la
commercialisation et le brevet de base
de lithium ion
comme je dis ça a été breveté en 79 par
hydro-québec le service et monsieur john
goodenough si le premier quart a mené la
la la la cathode de quatre vols donc
hydro québec nous un autre qu'on appelle
ça le core business c'est plus la r et d
y développer le matériau chercher
aujourd'hui on est en cela un
gouvernement business il ya un
abaissement québec il ya toute une
stratégie pour développer une filiale
filiale d'hydro-québec avec une
stratégie de nos ressources naturelles
un écosystème québécois quand même il
faut pas qu'on oublie on a des bons
universités québécoises
on peut les comparer terre la baston
naucelle silicon valley et je pense que
nous pouvons mettre le québec sur une
belle carte pour vos futures pour des
usines et on est capable de concurrence
y est
d'autres comme tesla autres à travers le
monde monsieur karim qu'est ce que votre
batterie
va changer parce que je crois comprendre
qu'elle est beaucoup plus petit et
qu'elle nécessitera peut-être moins
d'utilisation des métaux précieux
oui regardez juste pour corriger toutes
les batteries lithium-ion dont batteries
lithium-ion ou la batterie tout solide
il n'y a pas des métaux rares il n'y a
pas des matériaux précieux dans une
batterie aujourd'hui on appelle
lithium-ion
il ya une anode et cathode électrique
dans la lande on utilise du cube
collector du graphite est dû un peu de
silicium dans la cathode on utilise du
cobalt du nickel et du manganèse et le
collector c'est de l'aluminium
si on fait la somme algébrique de tous
ces matériaux toutes ces ressources
naturelles existent au québec
et si on développe la filière des
ressources naturelles au québec c'est
que il faut faire la première la
deuxième transformation qui berne
pourquoi parce qu'on à 100% notre
énergie elle est propre et coûte moins
cher et aussi on peut développer un
écosystème avec un fabricant de
batteries qu'il ya une stratégie
géographique est proche donc s'ils
s'allient matériaux et ont pensé au
québec aussi si on est dans un l'endroit
politiquement stable et on a accès de
toutes les marchés le marché de l'europe
le marché n'a milles du nord des etats
unis le mexique le marché de la mer du
sud est aussi là le marché de
l'asie-pacifique et ça ça nous donne
accès à peu près à 2 milliards de
clients et de plus on est proche aussi
des marchés on en périodes on a forgé un
chrysler est donc un à un en an annick
au système qui est impressionnant au
québec et on peut faire transformer nos
ressources naturelles
ici au québec vous avez vraiment ma
question je reviens juste une question
très pratico pratique les gens soupçon
parfois les batteries c'est toutes ces
histoires de batteries qui explose c'est
dû à quoi ou est ce que c'est juste une
légende urbaine où on a ajouté ce père
qui a explosé ou une pareille tesla une
voiture récemment ici à montréal pour
l'été dernier il y avait une voiture je
pense une hyundai qui a explosé on sait
pas pourquoi mais alors est ce que est
ce qu'il ya des choses qui sont faites
pour réduire ces risques là aujourd'hui
on a deux types de lithium ion on
l'appelle wikio me à 1 mc en séance
unique elle comporte aluminium qui sont
l'oxygène et on a des batteries
lithium-ion de fer phosphate
aujourd'hui la majorité des voitures
électriques utilisent du nickel compote
aluminium ou du nickel manganèse cowboys
avec l'occident
est ce qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
batteries lithium-ion l'électrolyte
c'est un historique inflammable ses
connaissances en revanche on explique
c'est un triangle de feu on à l'oxygène
on a les sens et on à la limite
la limite c'est quoi c'est le
court-circuit au l'accident
les sens et l'électrolyte inflammable et
l'oxygène vient de la cathode est oui
oui à un problème au niveau de la
sécurité
tout le monde travaille sur la spree
mais en revanche il faut pas avoir peur
lorsqu'on conduit une voiture électrique
aujourd'hui parce qu'on utilise qu'on
appelle ça des batteries management
system excusez-moi mômes au moment de 6
2 et star de batterie de gestion assez
protégé et on fait aussi sûr qu'il ya
liquide de refroidissement en de
maintenir toujours la température et on
met la batterie dans une cage vraiment
pratiquement blindés donc les risques et
peut aimer en revanche nous nous dit ben
là on a déjà développé des batteries
sécuritaire avec le cargo soit le fer
phosphate donc ya pas de risque mais en
revanche en densité d'énergie au niveau
lithium-ion et à 25% moins nous on veut
changer la trilogie au complet ça veut
dire que dalle et de la batterie
lithium-ion à une batterie tout solide
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la
nôtre la cathode électronique elle est
solide
tout sent qu'il y aura plus de problème
de feu est en revanche on va augmenter
la densité d'énergie augmenter la
densité d'énergie c'est quoi aujourd'hui
la densité d'énergie aller de 250 watts
heure par kilogramme on veut aller vers
500 watts par kilogramme
ça veut dire quoi - qui la danse et
d'énergie
ça veut dire qu'on va augmenter
l'autonomie mais si on augmente
l'autonomie ont valu un peu près de 400
à 800 km une fois qu'on arrive à 800
kilomètres donc on n'aura pas à tout en
charger la batterie talent réel problème
du conte donnions dès qu'on dit le
problème des installations dans les
appartements donc on vraiment le temps
est aussi le prix ce que nous
aujourd'hui le prix d'une batterie
lithium-ion au niveau kilowattheure n'en
parle un prix de 200 à 220 les curateurs
nous on veut réduire le prix de cette
batterie parce que cette batterie
elles demandent pas beaucoup d'énergie
demande pas beaucoup d'étapes de
fabrication ont valu vers 100 dollars le
kilo à terre et à 100 $ kilowattheures
par pac
on n'aura pas besoin de subventions et
le prix de la voiture électrique et se
rapproche de la voiture à essence
est-ce que vous avez un véhicule
électrique c'est une question qui est
gardée croissent après 25 ans la même
avec les batteries au plan là je roule
toujours avait il faut que je donne
l'exemple
aujourd'hui je roule avec et
une voiture mitsubishi progreen qu'il
fait 65e 65km maintenant maintenant on a
même eu de bonnes on pense au futur donc
on a une bonne qu'on appelle vie
culturelle de culte orange en france nos
styles au niveau du réseau parce que
plus tard le client et devient
participatif et mon auto dans quelques
années je peux vendre l'électricité à
hydro-québec 30 ans de femmes puis
inscrit ma patrie comme génératrice pour
ma maison
ouais écoutez blague à part vous auriez
pu être milliardaire et vous offrir en
ce moment une tesla
c'est pas le cas vous avez décidé de
travailler pour le secteur plein ouest
question qui se pose
oui généralement aussi si je suis juste
à à l'université ou à l'extérieur
la propriété intellectuelle appartient
50% aux chercheurs c'est le contraire
chez hydro-québec toute la propriété
intellectuelle elle appartient à hydro
québec sera un bon sens et à la
patrimoine québécois et on reçoit moins
tous les chercheurs ici on reçoit 0 $
sur cinq ans 550 inventions je peux être
d'une dizaine de millions jusqu'à 1
milliard mais c'est une passion qui
déborde
c'est un choix personnel et moi j'ai
pris une direction avec mon équipe de
travailler pour les intérêts supérieurs
du québec d'hydro québec l'humanité
comme on dit en argent aille dans lequel
tout match au nord de manille mais c'est
le fait tous qui j'ai un excellent
salaire je dois avoir une bonne retraite
et il le fait que j'essaierai de ramener
un grain pour guider l'humanité le
réchauffement de la planète on le sait
assez bien écouter fantastique on est
bien content vous avoir eu l'émission
vous a adopté parce qu'on vous appelle
monsieur monsieur karim haggui touchés
merci beaucoup
alors c'était karim zaghib directeur du
centre d'excellence en électrification
des transports à hydro québec va ce
merci nous avons ramené cet invité à
merci à lui aussi de faire un travail
mais vini venue des idées pendant qu'il
parlait
aussi de propriété intellectuelle on la
donne 100% aux patrons à radio canada
sans recevoir un sou il ya des choses
communes j'ai aussi mes une idée m'est
venue il parle toujours de ses batteries
moi j'ai quelque chose de très simple
alors proposé je pense que ça peut être
étudiée c'est une pomme de terre
je pense ça pourrait servir de batteries
j'ai une idée comme ça sur laquelle je
travaille des pauvres faisaient faire
enfin oui alors pas au courant
d'expérience aux primaires avec la pomme
de terre
on a fait nos papilles de vos pas vous
étiez plus avancé mon père produisait
pas été producteur de poids de pommes de
terre c'est en face c'est vrai oui mais
le fait faillite à l'époque on peut pas
vendre sa hydro québec
alors écoutez ça enfin je fais beaucoup
de farcir yen reste ce que je raconte
peut-être ce qu'ont à moitié est-ce
qu'elle reste une question oui la grosse
boule
mais avant la grosse boule je sais que
j'ai perdu 20 points vous piaffez
d'impatience
on va y aller à la grosse boule puisque
vous êtes né temps à perdre 50 boul
ben ali vous en avez perdu seulement en
a 78 ans je pensais qu'on avait perdu
dès la première question la rue bon il
va changer de compliquer pas les choses
nous on avait perdu 30 seulement sur 50
jusqu'à maintenant mais à 5 en or c'est
sur ça
sur scène on est à 70 70 très bien alors
faisons pour nous j'aurais fait un bon
avocat parce que vous êtes confondues le
troisième bull grosse question
alors voici on la fiche au début de 19
films de 2019 il y avait combien de
véhicules électriques hybrides hybrides
et hybrides affrontera sion à l'hybride
aussi inclure ça sur la planète est-ce
que c'est moins de 6 millions est-ce que
cb - 2 5 millions ou est ce que c'est
c'est moins de 26 millions à gérer pour
nous attendait alors la première fois
j'ai entendu devait parler des véhicules
hybrides toyota prius quelque chose
comme ça ça fait but
bon entre a et b ça c'est quelque part
un driver selon chacun de nous prend à
sur 10 et 1 californie il en avait 40
millions d'habitants mais c'est plus qui
comme les quinze ans les japonnais de
l'autre côté norvégienne l'autre partie
on s'est parlé on va foncer sur le sais
vous allez pour le moins de 26 est-ce
que je devrais l'aller j-10 est d'accord
d'origine avec le succès à lundi pour
lancer le bateau va dire quelque chose
aux âmes alberto qui s'appelle le boulot
smash de beauf lost htc ce smash tmh
tembo en obtient alors cela ils ont
découvert des ossements de deux nouveaux
nés
vous voulez nous dire quoi on sait bien
on va regarder a affiché la bonne
réponse c'est ça ne ment pas et la régie
en reste 70 puisqu'elle n'a participé
qu'à la deux êtres à la troisième
question alors oui la régie il serait ce
que seulement à fin d'émission à propos
de batterie je ne sais pas ça me revenir
à l'idée je me suis rappelé qu' est-ce
que vous savez que carey nous arrive
dans son équipe sur l'histoire des
batteries stockage d'électricité ce
n'est pas juste des batteries de voiture
c'est aussi ils vont dans des
communautés où ils peuvent mettre des
containers comme une grosse batterie qui
peut fournir l'électricité à voir par
exemple celle en or chez je connais pas
ces endroits touchés chez deux
communautés amérindiennes ils auront
fourni avec les listes avec le solaire
ils peuvent récupérer d'électricité dans
des batteries puis les acteurs dans le
sait vraiment dans leurs recherches il
ya une partie
transport et une partie stockage
dynamique et la désinsectisation des
infrastructures c'est l'avenir j'ai aimé
le fait que ça qu'on peut remettre
l'électricité à hydro québec
là on peut faire du beurre électriques
quelque chose que vous peu nous nous
autres on peut aussi produire à acheter
allait acheter le nom le nom tout de
suite hubert l'état je vous donne la
libéralisation d'électricité s'était
déjà fait deux côtés d'hubert hubert
isation d'électricité ce jeu on va vous
laisser sur la dernière vidéo et pour en
savoir plus depuis samedi on vous avait
parlé d'une auto qui explosait vous
allez voir on a préparé cette vidéo sur
les documents qui accompagne cette
émission genre il attend canada sur
notre page web
on montre ce à dire si ce reportage en
tout je pense que le deuxième c'est
concernant ce véhicule automobile qui a
exposé exposer sa a été exposé à un
certain qu'il a exploité la deuxième
voilà une des passerelles enquête sur
l'explosion d'une voiture électrique à
montréal dans un garage d'une résidence
et ressortir des peyrouses mans qui
avait personne sinon d'autres reportages
de canada doit résolument pour en
mouvoir des autos les autobus urbains
vraiment real ya un autobus son projet
pilote l' electrical récemment qui est
sorti puis à la dot d'autres nouvelles
notamment la chine qui s'impliquent qui
pourrait déjouer les projets de
plusieurs et en attendant les avions
électriques comment les rendre plus
écologique sa fille il ya quelques
semaines à peine ou être des génies sion
ont par les avions électriques sans s'en
viennent mais en attendant il va falloir
dépolluer le ciel il ya des gros
problèmes à ce sujet là à ce sujet la
voilà pour ceux qui veulent lire et
quand il ya aussi l'article café maryse
sur karine jarry
quand il a eu son prix aussi tout à fait
parce qu'on voyait teinte repasser les
images déjà sur les braises qui est allé
sur place mais on peut trouver beaucoup
d'informations simplement on t'a pas son
nom car il arrive d'un envol avec tout
ce qu'il faut gouvernement du québec
tout ce qu'il a reçu comme prix c'est
vrai j'ai récemment la stratégie du
gouvernement sur le lithium sur
l'industrie du lithium au québec aussi
c'est vraiment serré sans savoir qu'il
ya deux ou trois semaines donc
donc il ya des choses a ajouté zhu et va
jouer c'est exactement ça me remet mon
travail
écoutez c'est tout pour cette semaine la
semaine prochaine on va parler de la
santé oms a parlé d'un problème de santé
important merci balladur a pas de
surprise la sna français alors à la
semaine prochaine
merci
[Musique]